if you happen to be in Iowa this week
you can catch a satanic
altar uh put up on display at the Iowa
state capital this was put up by the
satanic temple the co-founder of the
satanic temple says this is a symbol of
the satanists right to religious
freedom of course Satanism is not
entitled to any rights whatsoever and
the founding fathers certainly wouldn't
have thought so and no no one even the
great Defenders of religious freedom not
so long ago would have ever defend this
but this this is now what religious
freedom is taken to mean that you can
have a a symbol of baffet or the devil
on display and you have a right to that
in a government
building the founder of the satanic
temple says we're going to really relish
the opportunity to be represented in a
public forum we don't have a church on
every street corner uh my feeling is
that if people don't like our display in
public forums they don't have to engage
with them they don't have to view them
okay if you're a normal person you
probably have a problem with this now
some some of you you might not some of
you might say oh whatever it's dumb it's
silly the satanic temple there are just
a bunch of edgy Reddit tier atheists
anyway who cares what they want to do I
don't like it I don't want my country to
exalt satanic symbols I think that's bad
I don't want shrines to Satan in my
government buildings I think that's a
bad thing to do and doesn't speak very
well of our country and I want it out
and I want to ban it and I I'm this
would not be a new ban this would be
reinstating a ban that existed for the
entire history of our country until
approximately five minutes ago uh I
think that would be good I think that
would be normal and American and right
now you might look at that and say well
it's okay it doesn't really matter I
don't like it it seems wrong but hey you
know religious freedom
right so then you got to ask the
question if if you know this is wrong
but the the premises that you have about
religion and politics lead you to saying
that this is fine how do you reconcile
those things one of them is you it can't
simultaneously be good and bad so which
is it how do you
reconcile your natural opposition to
Satan statues in our state capitals with
religious freedom you can
either say yeah Bring it on Bring on the
satanic altars let's put them in all our
our state capitals let's bring them to
Washington DC you can either say that
most of you probably won't think that or
you can totally throw out religious
freedom which some of you might want to
do but it's probably practical in
America or there is a third option the
third option is you can
circumscribe what religious freedom
means not merely on your own preferences
or you know a naked political power grab
but you can set limits on what religious
freedom
means through tradition informed by
reason you don't need to just pluck it
out of thin air or have it be a matter
of your own preferences you can say look
here's what religious freedom has always
meant in America it's never
included opposition to God it's never
included it's it's included broad
religious toleration for different
people who worship God in different ways
but it's never included opposition to
God or outright denial of God that was
just really never part of it and so
we're not going to allow that no
satanists no atheist altars none of that
you you can we can have a broad amount
of religious toleration without saying
that you're you have a freedom from
religion or freedom to to worship the
devil in the state capital
that's what you can do Libs should love
this Libs love saying that no right is
absolute until they want their Satan
statues in the state capital then all of
a sudden the rights are absolute your
right your first amendment right's not
absolute when you want to talk on a
college campus and you're a conservative
your First Amendment right is not
absolute when you want access to the
Public Square on social media to to say
your conservative points of view your
Second Amendment right oh that's never
absolute you're you're only allowed to
have a musket you're this right you're
that right but you know the the the
supposed right never really articulated
in American Juris Prudence or political
philosophy to have a Satan statue that
that that's the one that is AB absolute
no of course not of course not I don't
think that the Satan statue falls under
any serious conception of Freedom or
religion religion is a habit of virtue
that inclines the will to give to God
what he
deserves but even if you do even if
you're a little confused on what freedom
and religion mean how about you how
about we just Avail ourselves of history
and reason and tradition that's what
tradition is about it's not about just
blindly giving up your own ability to
think and and have your own opinions
it's just allowing your opinion to be
informed by every other smart person who
ever lived don't you think it maybe
there's a chance that every other smart
human being who ever lived for all of
history uh might be able to teach you
something that you haven't just figured
all of it out better than all of the
other smart people well there it is
welcome to traditionalism There It Is
Well you're a conservative
wonderful wonderful to have you we got
to talk about these things when you when
you want to talk you got to check out P
talk right now go to Pur talk.com P talk
has you covered for the holidays with a
free Moto g5g phone no gimmicks or
trading necessary just sign up for Pure
talks unlimited talk unlimited text and
15 gigs of data you can get all of this
for just 35 bucks and you will get the
Moto G 5G phone for free you need to
move fast because these phones are
almost gone so if your current phone is
on life support upgrade for free with
Pure Talk the new Moto g5g phone boasts
a tway battery life an exceptional quad
pixel camera and a whole lot more Pure
Talk gives you America's most Dependable
5G Network at half the price so make the
switch today go to P talk.com nkw to get
this exclusive offer and select the plan
that is right for your family p talk
gives you America's most Dependable 5G
Network at half the price make the
switch today that is Pur
talk.com to claim your free Moto g5g
phone with a qualifying plan Pure Talk
put simply is smart
wireless head on over there right now
these guys have been great supported the
show they give you the best network out
there head on over to pure talk today
unfortunately there's a state
representative in Iowa representative
John dunwell who seems like he means
well but he you can see him grappling
with this conflict between uh we don't
want to worship the devil in our
government buildings but you know we got
religious freedom and he he doesn't seem
to figure it out so he has this very
very long post about it on social media
and he vacillates he says well as a
follower of Christ I think this but as a
state representative I think this but as
a follower of Christ I think this but as
a and it's so long I didn't even read
the whole thing
because he's just twisting himself into
knots the the first error is to think
that you can actually separate yourself
into little compartments you can't you
can recognize that uh you have certain
duties and certain circumstances but to
suggest that that you are multiple
different people and you can totally
divorce your moral views from your
political life is just completely insane
politics is how we all get along
together and all laws legislate morality
so here's what he says he says my
response to the Satan statute is a
follower of Christ my response is a
state representative my observations and
response as an Iowan state
representative and
Pastor as a follower of Christ I
certainly find a display from the
Satanic Temple objectionable it stands
in direct opposition to my faith and
would be classified is
evil not a new experience for me or my
family the word of God continually warns
about the dangers in our world In
fairness many other religions or
non-religious people have the same
perspective about Christianity put a
pause right
there yeah they do they're
wrong they're
wrong you you say x is good Y is
evil other people say Y is good X is
evil one of you is right and you can't
just shrug your shoulders one of you has
to be right because you're going to live
together and you're going to enshrine
good things in the law and you're going
to prohibit bad things in the law too
that's what law does so you can't just
say well you know look I my perspect
right where does your perspective come
from is it completely uninformed it's
just it's just a a reflex of your mind a
a uh a contortion a gesticulation it's
not informed by reason no it's informed
by reason you think it's true and So you
you're going to broadly follow that yeah
it's a good idea says my observation as
an Iowa and a state representative I
don't want the state evaluating and
making determinations about religions
I'm Guided by the First Amendment of the
US
Constitution first of all are you are
you I don't know that's the first
amendment was never understood to
enshrine Satanism so I I'm not sure that
you are you're enshrined by a liberal
revisionist view of the First Amendment
but even here's a more basic question to
to representative dunwell and I don't
mean to single him out a lot of people
think it like
this are you are you a Christian first
or a liberal first I mean a lowercase L
liberal I mean the classical liberal I
mean whatever the good whatever good
kind of liberal you can think of what
what are you first are you a Christian
or that do you serve God first or do you
serve
some political ideology called
liberalism which is it when they come
into
conflict man cannot serve two masters
which is it not hard for me I talk to
Christians I talk to religious Jews I
talk to Muslims I told you there's broad
agreement I think among people on
broadly how to serve God in public life
and how to have a good
Society I don't think the same can be
said of liberal look what liberalism's
done it's it's alienated people from
their society it's it's led to a kind of
skepticism where even guy who calls
himself a Christian pastor says well I
don't know some people think
Christianity is evil so the state needs
to lay off it I mean the man this is a
politician very sad very very
sad I've heard liberalism described a
liberal is one who who uh cannot take
his own side in an argument Bill Buckley
said it very well he said skepticism has
utility only when it leads to conviction
so what's the conviction what do we
believe what is it what do you actually
believe man what a great clip that was
now hold up hold up hey hold up ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael nlls
podcast we'll see you next time